let's turn now to the biggest story back
in Washington the Democrats threat to
shut down the government if they don't
get a daca deal giving amnesty to
hundreds of thousands of dreamers my
first guest was in that infamous meeting
last week when President Trump rejected
that weak gang of six plan and allegedly
uttered the horrible S word this
lawmaker has also offered his own daca
plan that is strong on border security
and immigration enforcement and the
president and the White House
complimented back on January 10th
we welcome the chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee Bob Goodlatte in
Washington congressman great to see you
I know you weren't at the meeting today
that general Kelly had with a
Congressional Hispanic Caucus but he did
have some interesting things to say and
I want to play a sound byte for you this
was general Kelly on Bret Baier tonight
let's watch there's been an evolutionary
process that this president has gone
through as a campaign and I pointed out
to all of the members that were in the
room that they all say things during the
course of campaigns that may or may not
be fully informed
but this president if you've seen what
he's done he has changed the way he's
looked at a number of things campaign to
governing at two different things okay
when we hear words like evolved
congressman a lot of Trump supporters
get nervous on issues like the wall
Mexico was supposed to pay for it where
are we well I think we're in a strong
position because general Kelly secretary
Neilson of the department homeland
security have been up here a lot on
Capitol Hill I wasn't at the meeting you
just referred to but I know that they
are conveying to members of Congress
that the president is keeping his
commitment both with regard to security
at the border and to making sure that
when people get across the border and
they're apprehended or even turn
themselves in that they are safely
returned home and are not simply
released into the interior of our
country we've got to end chain migration
a president as you know
it had a great meeting at the White
House last Tuesday millions of Americans
got to see that on television live or on
tape and they know that this president
is trying to solve this problem but to
solve the problem you've got to stop and
make sure that people respect the rule
of law and so that's what Republicans in
the House are all about that's what the
legislation we have introduced is all
about yes we'll do something for the
daca recipients but we've got to make
absolutely sure and that as the Speaker
of the House has said this shouldn't be
allowed to continue and therefore we
have we have lots of border security
lots of interior enforcement to get to
specifically what that is your
enforcement but your bill your bill you
co-authored it with Raul Labrador it has
a lot at most if not all of what the
president has asked for to give this
relief to the daca folks you do why
isn't why does Mitch McConnell I want to
play a sound bite for you from Mitch
McConnell earlier today he seems
confused about what the president can
sign let's watch he's not yet indicated
hmm what measure he's willing to sign as
soon as we figure out what he is for
then I would be convinced that we were
not just spinning our wheels wait a
second spinning wheels on January 10th
the White House came out in support of
your bill congressman how was that using
for Senator McConnell I'm not clear on
that well I think it's very important
that the House passed this bill so that
the Senate sees that there is strong
strong support for addressing daca but
making sure that we have strong borders
and making sure that our laws are
respected yeah we know all that
well I won't Paul Ryan bring this bill
up for a vote that would give this whole
conversation a lot of momentum don't you
think and take the wind out of the sails
of all these open borders types or
saying Oh Trump Trump's a racist Trump
does Trump doesn't want to help these
people
Trump uses foul language in the Oval
Office we're going to shut down the
government your bill gives him what he
said he will do and a lot of these
Democrats claim their for border
security and then you will you will take
this other you know toxic element
the equation why won't Paul Ryan bring
this up for a vote well I think where we
are taking steps in that direction and
the speaker and the leader have both
indicated today that they're going to
start having a member listening session
so that they can learn more about this
bill and get up to speed you listen to
the people I sound like I'm blowing
smoke toward you congressman but you
actually listen to the people and what
you did in your legislation we Kelly
tonight was saying on Bret Baier it's
only gonna be 700 miles and I go I guess
but that's not mean I thought the
president said he's evolving but you and
your bill actually you actually tracked
what the president campaigned on for the
most part with the with the daca piece
that you know we didn't campaign on but
I think the president has shown that
he's moving to compromise and all the
while Jeff Flake goes out there today
calls them essentially Stalin Lindsey
Graham's leaking elements of that
meeting I think the negativity is coming
from the same crowd that almost drove us
into the ground back in 2013 in 2007
with a gang of eight and those other
amnesty attempts and I don't like that
one bit
no neither do i and that's why we're
pushing hard for this bill and that's
why I think things are moving in the
right direction now and yes we have to
get the leader to bring this bill to the
floor of the house he better do so we
absolutely have to do it we also have to
get the members rallying behind it we've
been working hard on this bill for
months now we're educating the members
about what exactly is in this bill and
your viewers can help by letting members
of Congress know that they want to see
how important security measures brought
to the floor of the house for a vote and
Bing Schoen migration ending Visa
Lottery that we got we got people in the
Senate now want to just move the deck
chairs on the Titanic and give all the
Visa Lottery slots to the temporary
protected status people from hurricanes
that happened decades ago correct that's
correct and we absolutely yes the house
will not do that
that's absurd a non-starter so I don't
think the Senate will after after all
things are said and done as well I do I
think there are many many senators well
very gun-shy about that approach
congressman should we appreciate we
appreciate your joining us tonight and
explaining this to us and and and and I
think a lot of our viewers my listeners
on radio
they are jacked up about this and they
know what flake was up to and they know
what Lindsey Graham was up to and
they're not going to tolerate that's
nonsense thank you so much